mais nous faisons régulièrement la
chasse à la langue de bois se dira ce
vocabulaire souvent peu compréhensible
de l'administration mais même des hommes
politiques pardon messieurs
mais il faut que vous sachiez que vos
administrés ne comprennent pas toujours
vous répondre vos réponses à leurs
lettres alors de grâce ne leur parlait
pas trop de corps constitués ou autre
terminologie de ce style
regardez le résultat tel que l'a observé
gérard pas bio grâce à ses opinions sur
rue c'est le terme que nous employons
par dérision les rues aujourd'hui étant
celle d'angers et de tours dans les
grands corps de l'état qu'est ce que
vous verriez monsieur courroye
pourquoi parce qu'on le voit toujours
les résidents de choses comme ça on voit
toujours très
beaucoup plus fort que les beaucoup plus
grand que savez vous mademoiselle les
corps constitués
c'est des corps constitués à votre avis
qu'est ce que c'est c'est quand l'enfant
ban est on veut pas pas vannes est mais
se forme celle en payons
comment imaginez-vous la dissolution de
la chambre la dissolution d'un serveur
du maladroit ce qu'on voulait dire par
dissolution de la chambre basse issue
pour réparer un trou dans une
est ce que j'en sais moi une fois qu'on
a trouvé le trouve il ya des petites
panthères ont gravé en moi et on met de
la connait on est une rue style ou plus
simplement je vous parle des relations
extérieures vous voyez ce que je veux
vous dire vous parlez des dents là j'ai
des relations entre disons dans un
ménage ou quoi
vers l'agent du jeune avec rennes si
votre vie alors justement m a vaincu je
pense qu à partir du moment où on est
mariés on doit avoir une vie raisonnable
que l'on doit faire un couple uni et
chacun doit apporter sa contribution
le palais bourbon ah non productives
voyez ce que c'est
ouais je vois ce que ça mais moi je
crois pas que ça mais non j'ai en moi
pour alors de whisky bière
pas de discours quand je vous parle de
palais
whisky toute manière comment
imaginez-vous un portefeuille de
ministre
shaw palmer en cuir mais celui d'un
ministre est de et un crocodile
certainement connu pareille matière à 10
ans
plus noble que celui d'un ouvrier et
puis il ya certainement de l'argent
dedans enfin vous n'êtes pas pour les
changements de cabinet fréquents non non
quand s'est entretenu maintenu je veux
dire quand l'entretien était fréquemment
c'est à dire bah c'est à dire disons que
ça soit propre camp soit propre et puis
alors de temps en temps si par exemple
achat ne fonctionne plus ou moins bien
la faire apparaître tout homme bien
portant est un malade qui s'ignore
écrivait jules renard une évidence que
le langage médical tel qu'on le pratique
est tel qu'on le découvre dans roulette
n'est pas près de modifier vous allez
voir dans l'opinion sur rue de vire à
repas bio que les gens bien portants
rencontrés au gré des trottoirs sont du
terme lourd malades d'incompréhension
devant le vocabulaire de nos cher
docteur et pharmaciens de circulation
oui à quelques tours de circulation au
moment surtout des cars de ramassage des
élèves qui partent comment ça se passe
et bien il y à un arrêt de la
circulation en fin des troubles c'est
surtout place de la république en face
du prisunic si vous avez remarqué alors
la tachycardie à votre avis qu'est ce
que ça serait kapicka habille une
province de normandie la picardie
normandie picardie puisque vous pouvez
regarder petit coeur by l'oto rhino ça
vous dit quelque chose
qui ne me parle pas de mécanique ne
s'intéressera à mécanique l'oto rhino ça
vous dit quelque chose dont je connais
pas ce soir là n'a alors pas du tout que
pensez-vous des affections bénignes
madame personnellement j ai pas beaucoup
c'est pas mon truc
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire of je n'aime pas beaucoup
ces rencontres de coin de rue où c'est
je vous disais je suis pour le grand
tabou quelque chose de solide
le scorbut scorbut excepté pour pour les
compétitions de haut niveau où on
s'intéresse à un score pour des matches
de football de rugby très important
mise à part ces grands matches c'est la
rencontre je n'accorde pas d'importance
au but et au score c'est plutôt l'esprit
du jeu et la qualité du sport qui
m'intéresse
la voie buccale oui oui oui j'aime la
voie buccale
c'est à dire les chansons oui mais
classique ainsi que la voie buccale
mêleront chanson classique chanson
classique oui la tête et les jambes de
cédric elle avait une voie buccale où
elle a chanté au trait aux attentes
alors qu'est ce qu'un adjuvant monsieur
b hier des allures de sa durée de
carrière
l'activité est ce que c'est qu'un
adjuvant et c'est un des hauts lieux du
souletin est au dessus de sa richesse
enfin quand je vous parle de pathologies
voyez ce que je veux dire
il s'agit de quoi alors non pas qu'ils
aient fait un pataquès est chez soi la
pâte bcg ça vous dit quelque chose
oui qu'est ce que ça peut être bon chic
bon genre
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire quelqu'un
qui présente bien par exemple
travaillent chez vous je sais pas je
vous posais que kiki qui se sera aussi
bien patrick poivre d'arvor qu
il est bcg alors bon chic bon genre
voilà est-il pénible à votre avis de
garder des séquelles
[Musique]
j'ai vu un peu ce que c'était il a gardé
des séquelles lui même
je pense à ces pays effectivement
qu'est ce qui vous paraît pénible dans
le fait de garder des séquelles toujours
agréable
garder les moutons en chef dehors et
puis c'est qu'elle wisekey les garderiez
droite garde aurier pas de séquelles
ça viendrait pas pourquoi promis de
réparer plus tard
la semaine dernière j'ai
pas bio dans sa grande fresque intitulée
au pignon sur rue avait abordé le thème
de l'accord musical et de ses
difficultés se laver cela vous avez
passionné vous nous aviez téléphoner ça
va donc chercher le coupable est
aujourd'hui géré a voulu sonder la
france au sujet d'un certain ludwig van
bay de son ami jean sébastien de leur
célèbre compères wolfgang amadeus la mer
de debussy ça vous dit quelque chose lui
d'accord mais elle alors lui qui était à
mon avis c'était un peintre non je pense
et la mer de debussy
non non je connais vraiment pas toute la
famille un parent lui qu'on entend
parler comme ça mais autrement le fait
qu'il ait fait des fugues jean sébastien
bach pas d'accord qu'il fasse ce qu'il
voudra à part être malhonnête malheur
est un c'est sa musique qui m'intéresse
je viens écouter on peut dire c'est une
manolete d'avoir fait des fugues non
mais jean-sébastien bach
ouais c'est un personne n'est à l'abri
de perdre la walkyrie ça vous dit
quelque chose et qu'il est dans la boîte
avec plusieurs types massoud en dise et
puis c'est très bon comment
imaginez-vous le boléro de ravel madame
j'imagine qu'on peut le faire de
plusieurs formes où on peut faire
arrondi
10 avec tourné avec un petit noeud ou
alors tout simplement avec des boutons
ce moment là on le fait un point tombe
avec trois petites boîtes
avez vous entendu parler d'othello
monsieur
l'écrivain non un peintre othello mais
je pense que c'est quand même assez
assez gênant c'est bien pratique d'avoir
le courante à domicile si je vous dis
cosi fan tout qu'est-ce que ça vous dit
tout et j'y connais rien du tout alors
cosy j'espère c'est à dire eh bien c'est
ali d'angle avec un immeuble de voix
est-ce que la périchole vous voyez ce
que c'est monsieur percolateur cancer et
qui marche électriquement c'est un petit
parc de la theurre électriques pour
faire le café près c'est quoi avez vous
entendu parler du mariage de figaro
madame
un regroupement social de entre le
figaro télé 7 jours l'europe
[Rires]
marie-claire jours et vous parlez de la
truite de schubert
elle est la connaît pas expliqué moi ce
que c'est ce que vous connaissez dans ce
domaine vont alors rien du tout dans le
poisson je vous dis j'ai échoué pêcheurs
que sont les études de chopin à votre
avis bien je crois le bateau là je crois
le baccalauréat qui à cette époque était
quelque chose de formidable
vous comprenez qu'on parle des polonaise
de chopin non je suis pas d'accord là
dessus la vie privée des gens
dans cette personne elle est
c'est pas parce qu'il a il a fait il a
écrit ainsi de suite pour doit s'occuper
de la vie privée des gens les trompettes
d'aïda ça vous dit quelque chose
non monsieur bambino d'accord à bobino
ça c'est que cette chanson que je
connaisse dalida tu peux vous en sentez
un petit morceau ce que je veux bien
combiné au bobino
ça c'est bien que tu l'as d'or bambino
et gratte gratte sur ta mandoline et mon
petit bambino ta musique est plus joli
que sous le ciel de l'italie mais c'est
pas les trompettes d'aïda annoncé
bambino 2 de david haye est de l'eau
dans le gaz comme vous l'affirmez dans
votre courrier comme va tenter de nous
prouver dans un instant gérard pas bio
mais notre spécialiste du sondage
express au coin de la rue c'est branché
sur 2000 volts pour faire le va-et-vient
micro à la main et je vous jure que six
interlocuteurs si certains
interlocuteurs en tout cas vous vous
paraître disons entre guillemets à la
masse aucune des réponses n'a été prise
de force
si je vous parle de prise de force c'est
un peu dégueulasse à calais mais qui
viole une bonne assise au maire avance
au poste ils sont une nuit à prendre
l'air lorsque le maire commence et jean
gardés à vue pendant dix jours et se
relâcher après vient de me cambrioler
comme ils l'ont fait chez moi dans ma
caravane c'est dégueulasse être branché
à la main
ça veut dire que ça circule pas très
bien là dedans là dedans la petite tête
c'est une erreur je pense que être
branché à l'ama souhaite tout faire de
l'élitisme dans les deux cas c'est pas
le
c'est parce qu'il convient quand je vous
parle du va-et-vient voyez ce que je
veux dire
oui très bien oui qu'est ce que c'est
c'est des choses qu'on ne parle pas
comme ça dans la rue ces choses intimes
ça c'est pas toi quand je vous parle
duval vient classique voyez ce que je
veux dire oui qu'est ce que c'est pour
faire ça traditionnellement je pourrais
peut-être un quart d'heure une
demi-heure faire ça
voyez ce que je veux dire quand je parle
de va et vient qu'est ce que c'est
basset c'est classique
c'est normal c'est à dire oh ouais que
pensez-vous du va-et-vient
je suis contre les homosexuels
le branchement vous voyez ce que celles
et ceux qui tout ces corridas alors il
vaut mieux un branchement individuel ou
un branchement collectif que pensez-vous
du principe de la conduite forcée
je suis ni pour ni contre seulement la
personne qui a fait un choix comme un
abbé par exemple ne peut pas se promener
facilement rue saint-denis ou aborder
des filles comme un agent de police ne
peut pas faire du vol à la tire ou se
chahuter dans la rue devant tout le
monde
voyez-vous ce quel tarif dégressif
monsieur dégressif c'est pour nous
enlever les graisses tous là où ça
investissements au pantalon à la veste
sur tout ça dans quelques s'est encastré
basse et l'ablation du prépuce bon
comment ça se fait c'était une incision
que ça avec eux dit story avec un truc
comme ça qu'est ce qu'il faut faire une
saignée pour encastrer puisque non
puisque déjà voyez vous ce qu'est la
baguette électrique monsieur oui oui
j'ai déjà mangé cette vague état qu'est
ce que c'est c'est pas croustillants
comme la baguette au feu de bois sa
photo fait le même coup pour paris bien
qu observateur chez vous bientôt on a
coupé les colzas les blés les orge et
blé dur
alors quel type de résistance vous
connaissez sur la résistance pendant la
guerre 39 45
voyez vous ce qu'est le poteau
électrique oui qu'est ce que c'est c'est
le pot-au-feu fait été cité et alors et
alors c'est formidable
et voici donc
bio et son micro trottoir tout ce que
vous avez toujours voulu savoir sur le
sexe n'est ce pas mon cher woody sans
jamais oser le demander
le détournement de mineure travail en
dessous et l'autre qui travaille aussi
dans quel domaine en général et le
mineur de fond en dessous qu'est ce que
c'est que l'insémination se former ses
formes et des des curés des jeunes purée
de pouce à nos séminaires vous
connaissez vous l'insémination pourquoi
je travaillais les parties car et
monsieur qu'est ce que c'est une partie
carrée ça peut être une partie
géométriques et à quatre faces égale
donc c'est une partie carrée par exemple
d'un élément on peut avoir une partie
karen part directement une partie
triangulaire etes-vous monogame monsieur
non support maintenance et là c'est la
stéréo maintenant c'était s'était passé
sa maîtresse que c'est monogame face à
ceux plus selon l'ancien système
est ce que c'est alors comme système
c'est un système de diffusion sur une
seule bande
comment voyez-vous les échanges de
partenaires monsieur les échanges de
partenaires disons que sur les sur le
point de vue mondial disons que allez on
réussit quand ça va bien pour le gaz
peut-être n'en sais rien maintenant
est-ce que ça continuera
les pervers qu'en pensez vous je ne les
connais pas je connais les pères blancs
mais je connais fois le pervers alors
que seraient les pervers des berges ou
du père bleus j'en sais rien du tout en
tout cas je ne connais que les pères
blancs une femme légère je sais pas vous
comptez 1 mais samedi c'est vous mettez
10 kilos de moins êtes vous pour le
principe de la maison close complètement
non la maison bien isolée mur toi
fenêtres double vitrage moi je les pose
est chez moi on a gagné 25% dont on a
fait une économie de 25 % de chauffage
êtes vous pour le ménage à trois madame
oui pourquoi pas parce qu'elle dit que
la femme doit être libre
c'est à dire pas tout le temps est à la
maison à faire le ménage c'est normal
que le mari est si tout le monde
travaille on me dit que sont la femme
les chiens sa liberté comme tout le
monde
que connaissez-vous comme ce catalogue
alors je connais je connais des
préférences des 3 suisses et puis la
redoute
l'homosexualité ça ne vous dit rien
absolument pas non non en tant que les
six voeux aux mots je comprends qu'on
s'en sert pour la lessive enfin pour le
ménage quoi mais cette histoire de
d'homosexualité j'avoue que tout autre
en savon pourrait très bien en place et
l'exhibitionnisme qu'est ce que c'est
votre avis c'est les juifs et sionistes
sioniste veut dire juif est alors
l'exhibitionnisme qu'est ce que ça
serait le retour des juifs en israël
nymphomane où vous voyez ce que ça
signifie monsieur qu'est ce que c'est
l'information qui fait l information
alors parmi les nymphomanes qui
connaissait vos valeurs si tron morosi
puis d'arvor il informe anne et emilie
la piñata monsieur maurice rowland
marignane dans les bouches du rhône nous
transmet un reproche et d'épilation
bravo pour vos savoureuse au pignon sur
rue nous écrit-il mais pourquoi diable
n'avez vous jamais encore fait un sort
au langage des technocrates et
politiciens qui compliqua plaisir la
langue française pour faire semblant
d'être cultive au plan de la pensée
rationnelle nous abondons dans votre
sens monsieur rolland à telle enseigne
que gérard pas bio notre spécialiste de
la communication à emprunter pour vous
l'infrastructure routière de l'hexagone
pour rallier nevers à aubenas plaque
tournante de leur région afrique et dans
le tissu urbain de ces deux sites
eiffarie l'attenté de deshors culte et
les carences linguistiques de ses
interlocuteurs et vous allez le voir au
niveau du comics et positivement valable
vous n'êtes pas natif de l'hexagone
monsieur non je suis natif de lyon la
variole d'ailleurs c'est quoi la région
de lyon c'est par l'hexagone
c'est le talent rhône et l'hexagone vous
le mettez ou alors les natifs de
l'hexagone c'est à quel endroit
alors là ça m'échappe à votre avis
l'hexagone qu'est ce que c'est ça de
côté
un quoi ronca deux côtés de côté oui
vous êtes sur wii qu'appelle-t-on le
complexe socioculturel monsieur mais
c'est quelqu'un qui a un complexe parce
que il ya l'impression qu'il ne connaît
pas assez de choses et puis il a du mal
à vivre en société
l'impasse budgétaire ça vous dit quelque
chose ça fait plusieurs années que
j'habite à ne vient jamais entendu
parler de ça fait plusieurs années que
j'habite à nevers je n'ai jamais entendu
parler ces deux causes un poste
militaire l'impasse budgétaire
à votre avis avant ce soit dans les
nouveaux logements qui sont faits au
cours lit voyez vous ce qu'est le
recyclage par exemple au moins avoir
arrêté de faire du vélo et puis en
reprendre des années plus tard à prendre
ce sport soit pour son plaisir et vous
avez été recyclés vous avez fait du
recyclage
enfin petit peu oui moi disons que
j'arrêtais champs non mon âge pas j'en
ai toujours fait toujours un peu quoi de
quoi ni vélo
voyez-vous ce qui est un champ de
perception globale par exemple oui bah
il me semble que c'est un
terrain qui est un terrain où il peut y
avoir des bêtes dessus on voit même des
fois je peux tentation quoi que ce soit
ou le percepteur ceux prélevés sur un an
pour la dessus qu'appelle-t-on les
coordonnées de quelqu'un mais c'est
quand quelqu'un met une super à
chemisier dans les mêmes coloris et
laisser ses coordonnées qu'est ce que
c'est déshabiller
voyez-vous ce qu'était un stéréotype
ouais c'est un type qui est branché car
brockman sur les oreilles d'écouter de
la musique à canal dans une oreille
l'aude dans l'autre un walkman sur la
tête pourquoi stéréotypes alors parce
que c'est la musique la musique à céret
aux voyous ce qu'on appelle la masse
salariale madame c'est la masse des gens
qui sont pas propres c'est-à-dire qu'ils
n'achètent pas de produits pour se laver
la maison donc comme exemple de masse
salariale qu'est ce que vous auriez
de plus en plus de pouls dans les écoles
de gens qui se laissent aller qui sont
pas rasé qui sont sales
vous dites ça pour moi non pas du tout
normalement quand j'entends pas rasé
j'entends qu'ils sont vraiment je ma
partie de la masse salariale non pas du
tout non les gens qui sont vraiment
qu'ils sont vraiment sale
[Musique]